I want you to take a moment and picture
the person who gave you your first big
career opportunity that person who took
a chance on you to do something you've
never done before
maybe before you are really ready do you
remember their name what they looked
like what that meant for you so I don't
know who you're picturing once their
name is or what they look like but I do
know something important about them in
some meaningful way they changed your
life now often when we talk about people
like this we call them Mentors
and we know that mentors are people who
give us advice share perspectives teach
us new skills and we're taught that
early in our career we should be
constantly scanning our working
environment always on the hunt for that
next mentor but not everyone who mentors
you has the power to help you move up to
get to that next level to advocate for
you when it really counts we need a
different word for that we'll call that
sponsorship and while I believe that
mentors matter we need sponsors to be
really successful so what is sponsorship
a sponsor sees the potential in you they
give you access to the kinds of
experiences and relationships that they
already have but you may not be able to
find on your own
and finally they'll put their own
reputation on the line to advocate for
your promotion whether it's to greater
responsibility or visibility now my
guess is that each of you could probably
tell me right now specifically
what your sponsor did for you but
sponsorship as a skill set is
generalizable it matters in every
profession so to picture this I want you
to picture a professional hero of mine
Yoda
now I loved Star Wars as a kid and I
loved it even more now because Yoda it
turns out is one of the greatest
sponsors of all time and here's why
when we first meet him Luke Skywalker
looks a lot more like a farmhand than a
Jedi Master
but Yoda sees through that to the
potential in him and decides to sponsor
him next he creates opportunities for
Luke to learn the kinds of skills he'll
need to be successful as a Jedi now
what's important about this is that he's
not just giving Luke advice he's giving
him access to the kinds of experiences
that Luke wouldn't have known how to
find on his own and finally and if you
haven't already been taking this
metaphor with a grain of salt you could
start now
Yodas dying act is to promote Luke he
makes him the last of the living Jedi
and that former farmhand goes on to save
the galaxy so at this point you might
think that this talk is about the
importance of finding your Yoda someone
to advocate for you and help you achieve
great things but actually this is a talk
about the importance of being a Yoda and
how to discover that greatness in others
and there's three important reasons to
do so first and this might be obvious
the sponsorship is a way to have a
measurable impact on somebody else's
life think back to the person you
pictured at the beginning you know what
a powerful impact that sponsorship had
for you but what if you would never met
that person or what if you had but they
just hadn't chosen you to take that
chance on where would you be now
that gap between what could have been
and what is is tangible to you although
perhaps hard to measure except looking
back so if you want to change lives
sponsorship is a way to fill that gap
for someone else now second and this is
perhaps less intuitive sponsorship turns
out to be good for the sponsor imagine
having a bench of people who feel about
you the way you feel about the person
you pictured what could you get done and
this isn't fluffy stuff a Deloitte study
found that 70% of people who
self-identify as sponsors reported
faster progression in their own careers
and this makes sense right because while
early in our careers were rewarded for
being strong individual producers there
comes a time when the things were asked
to achieve we can't do on our own
and that's when having a bench count and
there's something powerful about filling
that bench with people who are early in
their own careers there's a saying in
Silicon Valley that there's two kinds of
investors here people who invest in the
face book early and people who didn't
but wish they did now I can't tell you
how to invest your money but when you
invest in people early the return is a
network that's not just broader but
deeper and that social network is a
competitive advantage as a leader who
wants to get big things done so
sponsorships it's good for others and
it's good for you but there's a third
reason I want you to consider this and
that's because sponsorship is a powerful
tool for changing organizations from the
inside out no matter what stage you're
at in your own career and here's why we
know that organizations with diverse
teams have better business outcomes and
when I look at the world outside of our
classrooms I see lots of organizations
that have figured out how to hire fairly
diverse pools of talent at least at the
entry level but despite knowing this
her ship remains looking stubbornly like
it did 30 years ago this says to me that
there's something broken and how we're
moving people through organizations and
that it looks less like a ladder than
like a climbing wall where the ropes and
carabiners are only handed down to some
people I believe that in many ways it
comes down to who is getting sponsored
research shows that we're more likely to
spend time with communicate with trust
and by extension sponsor people who are
similar to us
it's literally human nature but in a
world where 80% of senior leaders and
97% of CEOs are men it's perhaps not
surprising that sponsorship can end up
looking in some ways like a
self-replicating system and again people
liking people who are like them doesn't
make them bad people just human but what
it says is that if we truly want to
create diverse organizations we have to
do what feels unnatural and be
intentional about looking for potential
and people who don't look like us no
matter who you are or what you look like
I hope the bench of people you build
looks less like this and more like this
so I hope that by being explicit about
what sponsorship is what it's done for
you and me and how we can step into that
role ourselves we could be the one to
break that self-replicating system and
it's not hard to do first we can start
now
so many of us picture our sponsors the
older and wiser but you don't have to
wait until you're a shriveled green 900
year old to do this no matter where you
are there are Luke Skywalker's behind
you wanting to go to your academic
institution work for your company or
move up into your current role we can be
intentional about looking for potential
and people who don't look like us we can
be Salsa about giving those people
access to the experiences and
relationships we already have that they
may not know how to find on their own
and finally we can be strategic about
advocating for their promotion so they
can benefit from our own attempts to
make it up that climbing wall to change
the world that we inherit we mean not
just more sponsorship but better
sponsorship and we need it to start now
not in another decade so I hope that
this top could be a kind of playbook for
us to go out into the world and be
intentional about sponsoring and I hope
you do so because it's a powerful way to
have an impact on somebody else's life
and I hope you do so because it's an
investment in yourself and your ability
to get big things done and I hope you do
so because it's a powerful tool for
changing organizations from the inside
out but most of all I hope you do so
because our legacies are not just the
businesses and bank accounts we leave
behind but rather the people whose lives
we've helped to build you know what it's
like to have found Euro to so go out and
find your Luke
[Applause]
[Music]